Could you tell us something of the
excellence of the night prayer
in Islam? As far as excellence of the
night prayer is concerned, there are
several verses in the Quran. There are
several hadith talking about it. I'll
just mention a few of them.
Allah says in the Quran in surah sagda
chapter number 32 verse number 16
talking about those people who are
people of paradise, those who go to
Jenna. And he describes these people
that their limbs do forsake the bed of
sleep and they call to the lord in fear
and hope. That means they leave aside
their sleep and they pray to Allah
subhanaa tala in hope and in fear in
tawa. And it continues and they give in
charity from the sustenance they have
given talking about the people of Jenna.
Further if you read in the Quran it's
mentioned in surah darat chapter number
51 verse number 17 and 18 that these
people talking of the people of Jenna
and the righteous people they sleep very
little in night
and during the early hours of dawn these
people they pray for forgiveness. Allah
further says in surah furan chapter
number 25 verse number 64 that these are
the people who spend their night in
adoration of their lord standing
and in prostration in kayam and in sujud
there are various verses in the Quran
there are various hadith talking about
the excellence of this night prayer our
beloved prophet wasallam said it's
mentioned in s muslim volume number one
in the book of fasting thing had number
our beloved prophet wasallam said that
the best prayer
after the prescribed prayers after the
prayers which are obligated which are
fur it is the night prayer
beloved prophet wasallam said it's
mentioned in say bkari volume number two
in the book of tahjud had number 1131
the beloved prophet said the best prayer
is the prayer of daisam
And the best fasting is the fasting of
daisam. And da dam he used to sleep the
first half of the night. Then he used to
spend the next oneird of the night in
praying to Allah subhana wa t'ala. And
the rest of it the one sixth of night he
to again sleep. Here again talking about
the excellence of the night prayer. A
beloved prophet wasallam said it's
mentioned in say bkari volume number two
in the book of taj had number 1142.
Abdullah prophet said that when a person
sleeps the satan he ties three knots at
the back of his head and after tying
each knot he whispers and he blows and
says the night is long so keep on
sleeping and when a person gets up and
remembers Allah subhanana wa ta'ala the
first knot is undone when he does the
voodoo the second knot is undone and
when he prays
the third knot is undone and the person
is energetic and inshallah he'll be on
the straight path for the full day. On
the other hand, if he gets up without
the name of Allah, without doing without
salah, then he's lazy and his heart is
mischief.
Our beloved prophet wasallam further
said it's mentioned in say Muslim volume
number one
in the book of salah had number 1656
obloved prophet said that Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala he descends to the
lowest part of the heaven in the last
oneird of the night
and he says that is there anyone who
wants to supplicate to me and I will
answer him is Is there anyone who wants
to ask from me and I will give it to
him? Is there anyone who wants to seek
forgiveness and I will forgive him? Is
there anyone who wants to invest a good
deed with me for I am not unjust and not
wasteful? And it continues till the
break of dawn.
And there are various excellence spoken
about the night prayer. For example, in
a sayai had ofdi book of supplications
had number 3579 our beloved prophet
wasallam said that
the servant is the closest to his lord
in the last oneird of the night and if
he asks him and if he prays to him
during this time it is the best time
that he can pray to Allah subhanaa tala
it's mentioned in a say hadith ofi
in the book of supplications
Hadit number 3499
that when a person asked that which is
the best time to prayer the beloved
prophet wasallam said that the best time
that a prayer will be answered is during
the last oneird of the night and after
the prescribed prayers after the
fablated prayers if you supplicate then
inshallah that's the best time to ask
for supplication and the last oneird of
the night it's mentioned mentioned in
sunnah Abu Dawud
volume number one in the book of salah
had number 1417 the beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said that
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has added one
more prayer for you that is a vitar
and if anyone wants to pray five rakat
in vitar he may do so if anyone wants to
pray three rakat for he may do
If anyone wants to pray one raat for
with her, he may do so. It's further
mentioned in Abu Daud number one in the
book of salat had number 133.
The beloved prophet wasallam said
that a person who gets up in the middle
of the night and prays to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala and wakes up his
wife and if she doesn't wake up then
sprinkle some water on her. Allah's
mercy and blessing is on such people.
And the hadith further continues that
Allah's mercy and blessing are on those
women who wake up in the middle of the
night and they pray to Allah subhana wa
tala and they wake up the husbands and
if the husbands don't wake up they
sprinkle water on them. So again it is
one of the best prayers after the
obligatory prayers. A beloved prophet
sallallahu alaii wasallam further said
it's mentioned sunah da number one in
the book of salah had number 1302 the
prophet's wife may Allah be pleased with
her she said that the prophet used to
always pray the
and he never missed it even when he was
sick and ill or lethargic he used to
pray even though he used to pray while
sitting he never missed it so This was
few of the hadith and fewic verses which
speak about the excellence of the night
prayer.